you're watching the press preview we'll
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with journalist and author rachel shabby
and editor of the jewish chronicle jake
wallace simons so let's see what's on
some of those front pages for you now
the observer reports the civil servant
investigating allegations of lockdown
breaking parties in downing street has
been given access to staff movements
including security swipe card
the sunday times leads with conservative
mp nisrat ghani's claim that she was
sacked from her ministerial post because
she was a muslim
the mail on sunday finds the prime
minister is at war with the so-called
white hall blob or top civil servants to
you and i over the working from home
the uk has accused moscow of planning to
install a pro-russian leader in ukraine
that's on the front of the sunday
telegraph as we were saying the cost of
living crisis is the focus for the
sunday people food writer jack monroe
has warned that those on low incomes
will starve due to the rising cost of
food
according to a poll in the sunday
express 72 percent think prince andrew
should be stripped of his duke of york
title
the sunday mirror splashes on tv
personality katie price who could face
prison for allegedly breaching a
restraining order
and we're joined tonight by rachel
shabby and jake wallace simons to take
us through the newspapers good evening
to you both let's start with the sunday
times and this exclusive and story that
we've been covering this evening um the
claims of nazareth ghani of uh being
told that her muslimness i think the
quotas made colleagues uncomfortable um
and uh she was very very upset by what
she was told by a whip so that the whip
story continues and take us into the
details of this rachel
yeah this story is both horrifying and
incredibly serious so
ghani as you said and i've been
reporting this evening
so she was fired from her ministerial
post in early 2020 she was transport
minister
um and she was told and this is a quote
um that she's quoting muslim women
minister status was making colleagues
uncomfortable this is absolutely
shocking it's straightforward racism she
says that she felt humiliated and
powerless she was also told not to make
a fuss about it
because if she did she would be
ostracized from her colleagues so it's
straightforwardly a case of anti-muslim
prejudice incredibly serious i have to
say not surprising um to the extent that
the conservative party has been mired in
anti-muslim sentiment for many many
years now it is both a huge problem and
one that the party itself is in just
gross denial about to the extent that in
2018 former party chair brendan lewis
said well i don't even think we've got a
problem but this is something that's
been going on for a very long time even
when we look at the prime minister and
his own uh islamic phobic comments about
muslim women which then caused a spike
in abuse and hate towards muslim women
on the streets um and then you look at
um you know counselors making
islamophobic comments and then um being
removed but then quietly reinstalled and
you look at the party's own membership
where a majority believe in muslim
conspiracy theories where just under i
think something like 43 say they
wouldn't want a muslim person
to lead the country and where the vast
majority believe that sharia law exists
in parts of london it is a huge problem
for the party it is appalling and it has
been in denial about it for a long time
and i just want to say
uh very difficult for someone like that
ghani to speak up about this so you know
respect and um full support and
solidarity with that
uh i must just say that that we have
been reporting that that mark spencer
chief whip has identified himself as the
whip involved in this story um and uh
he's saying that uh um the fact that she
was sacked or told she'd be sacked
because of her her muslim faith that's
completely false and defamatory
he says he came forward to ensure that
the other whips weren't drawn into the
matter
and so he identified himself he says
these accusations are completely false
and i consider them to be defamatory
i've never used those words attributed
to me it's disappointing that when this
issue was raised before muskani declined
to refer the mata to the conservative
party for a formal investigation i
provided evidence to the singh
investigation into islamophobia which
concluded that there was no credible
basis for the claims these allegations
were first made in march 2020 when miss
ghani was invited to use the formal
complaints procedure she declined to do
so so that's the the very latest coming
in from him this evening jake
i have to say also those tweets have
since been deleted we got this from
twitter um but they've since been
deleted
yeah so mark spencer uh appearing to to
to come forward and name himself as the
whip in question and make this very
strong denial in a very proactive way uh
does complicate the picture a lot and
makes it a lot more uh
sort of difficult to pin down i think
what needs to happen really is that a
full inquiry needs to take place to
establish the truth
of these very very serious allegations
so that we can all understand
what went wrong and the appropriate
action can be taken but this story
really comes in the context of a bigger
story which is about the culture of the
behaviour of the whips
in parliament william rag the back
venture is poised to report or to speak
to a police officer
about some of these allegations that
whips had blackmailed mps
in order to to behave in the way they
wanted
including having negative stories about
them in the locker and threatening to
release them if they didn't behave in
the way that the whips desired
and this really i mean i think to most
people involved in westminster this
comes as no great surprise because the
activities of the whips uh has long been
rather strong arm at uh at times um but
of course there is a line and uh really
it's for the uh you know the government
and now the police decide whether that
line has been crossed
yes sir we shall remain to be seen as to
what involvement that the police have in
this uh particular story also in the
sunday times there's a a piece about the
inquiry into parties turning the
spotlight on carrie johnson and her
friends what more do we know about this
rachel
well that's right so this has been
reported um by the observer as well so
as part of um subarray's so this senior
civil servant is looking into partygay
as part of her inquiries uh she's
potentially
uncovered another party so i believe
this would be the tenth
although honestly we've kind of lost cam
there's been so many and this is
uh thought to be friends of carrie
johnson and it's also thought to be
actually in the
prime minister's home so you know this
is taking the inquiry really into
a much deeper
level of um just
awful behavior at a time when as we know
everyone else was
putting up with the most difficult and
painful sacrifices in lockdown
do you think the importance of um
this inquiry by sue gray has been
overblown because we have had the prime
minister admit that that he went down to
the the party uh if we can call it that
in the garden and spent a short period
of time um and he has apologized
what more is the the inquiry going to
tell us that that we don't already know
well i mean rightly or wrongly it has uh
taken on this sort of um
you know
supercharged status as being the final
judgment
on what exactly went on in in downing
street uh during that period uh and uh
sue gray has had access to things like
emails that the public hasn't seen there
was in particular that uh email uh in
which the prime minister was warned
allegedly warned about the uh the folly
of such parties during lockdown
and she identified that
and has seen that so there is new
evidence that she has seen that the
public hasn't seen um i think that the
tories are really hoping that this is
not going to be
a death blow for the prime minister uh
but i think the public at large i mean
like you say you know in the court of
public opinion i think that the
consensus is pretty clear uh and boris's
plummeting popularity at the moment
um uh shows that very clearly uh but i
think in the in the in the bigger
picture you know politicians in the past
mps from tony blair to margaret thatcher
david cameron have come back uh from
close to death in the past uh and i
think a lot of tory activists and
members will be hoping that borrowers
can do the same because you know he does
have qualities to reach constituencies
particularly in the north that other mps
and ministers have not been shown to
have and so he really is vital to the
current picture of how the tory party
has been campaigning in in the last
couple of years
rachel what more does the express tell
us about the uh blackmail claims uh that
william rag is speaking to police about
so there seems to be quite a few of
these claims and this is being reported
by um several newspapers so
um so for instance chris bryant who's
the um
commons um standards committee chair for
the
labour chair uh has said that he's
spoken in the last few days to some
dozen
um
tory mps who have said uh that there
have been
you know claims of being blackmailed and
that that obviously is
not just terrible in terms of a bullying
workplace culture in parliament in
westminster but it's also
you know there's a legal issue there as
well which of course is why
uh the police may want to be getting
involved i think one of the aspects of
this is you know this sort of bullying
culture of the whips trying to you know
strong arm and peace to vote in a
particular way
that has been sort of going on for some
time it's not a new thing
um but i think what is particularly
uh
i mean that's awful for for mps and no
one should experience bullying in any
workplace of course
uh the the added component to this in
the conservative context is the reports
that
um mps are being threatened with things
being
removed you know projects being taken
away for their constituents so this idea
that you know constituencies essentially
would be used would be used as you know
blackmail
um
would be the collateral damage
of mps not voting in the way that the
whips want them to in a very very very
serious
very serious claim uh and and it must be
said that um
also uh we've noted that since the story
has been in circulation william has said
that he's been briefed against which
sort of even feeds in more to uh
evidence of this type of culture with
the whips and uh update mark spencer has
tweeted again uh that uh nizarak ghani's
claims are completely false that is that
the breaking
let's have a look at uh this section um
i want to talk about ukraine and have a
look at the telegraph front page um and
um liz trust has released some
intelligence which is quite unusual
about uh what the uk believes putin to
be doing and that is to to bring in his
uh pro-russia
regime um
give us a bit more detail jake
well this is as you said a very unusual
step by the foreign office to declassify
uh secret intelligence uh so quickly in
a live and unfolding situation
and what they are doing is uh is seeking
to reveal that president putin is
intending to invade ukraine and more
than that is intending to
install a pro-russian
puppet government if you like um uh mr
mariah being the candidate to be the new
prime minister now it should be said
that he has strongly denied that um but
but to my mind i mean the front office
would not uh plausibly release that
intelligence if it wasn't serious about
it and if it wasn't in all likelihood
true
so this is really raises raise the
stakes uh in ukraine which are already
very high indeed it places some pressure
on putin and sort of builds the case
for the west for nato and other western
powers to um to step up and provide even
more support for ukraine there'd been
some uh military aid to the ukraine from
britain in particular recently which
helps to bolster their armed forces but
i think there needs to be more of a
broad consensus in terms of a deterrent
particularly in terms of sanctions uh
there's been an idea of expelling russia
from the swift international banking
system
which is one
action that would have some far-reaching
consequences so i think it's an attempt
to really make the response from the
west more robust and a more and become a
greater deterrent to uh vladimir putin
before he does pull the trigger
rachel what purpose do you think it says
for liz trust to release this
information i mean might it just tip
putin over the edge and actually have
the the reaction that that nobody wants
you know i think that is actually the
most important question why is this
trust doing this as you as you said
yourself it's a highly unusual move to
release uh declassified int
oh intel i mean
you know it's not really
to have such faith in the reliability of
intel after the iraq war and the wmds is
is quite eyebrow-raising in itself
um the guardian has covered this story
as well and it points out that some of
the information that this trust claims
i.e about um
ukrainian uh
exiles working as as former former um
parliamentarians working as spies for
russia around this situation has already
been blown apart given that those people
in question actually live in moscow as
exiles and therefore are hardly
undercover um so i'm not sure what liz
trusts is seeking here this isn't intel
that has been corroborated by
any other country i don't think uh and
it does seem that the uk is seeking to
perhaps put some clear water between
itself and the eu like a demarcation
um because it's been saying you know the
eu isn't doing enough we need to do more
but of course this could just be
um sort of empty saber rattling and a
bit of a distraction from the prime
minister's current woes yeah it has to
be said that the foreign officer is
saying that they have information that
um mr murray was being considered by
russia as a candidate to lead ukraine
but they have declined to publish the
actual intelligence itself and miss
trust called the intelligence evidence
that russia was trying to subvert
ukraine and called for an end to the
kremlin's campaign of aggression but mr
mouriev himself dismissed the
accusations as stupid and absurd
pointing out that he has been subject to
russian sanctions himself so interesting
that the actual intelligence hasn't been
published itself and let's move on to
the times front page and jake take us
into this story the headline there
metaverse already rife with sexual
predators
i mean this is a story frankly that i i
don't understand i mean apparently
there's something called the metaverse
which is a virtual space that you access
by putting on these oculus goggles and
then you can see things in three
dimensions and everyone's represented by
avatars which as to my mind seem like
big cartoons and you can speak to them
and interact with them microsoft has a
platform um that you can use right now
um and it all just
frankly makes me feel very very old
indeed and i can't understand why
anybody would want to use this i mean
isn't the real world good enough isn't
facebook good enough and twitter and all
the rest of it um and it seems like the
only people who are using it are sexual
predators and racists and transphobes
and all the rest of it uh surprise
surprise
they're all um you know being very
offensive in this virtual space um
because i suppose they can't be in real
life so uh that to me seems to be the
top and bottom of the story yeah uh yeah
quite quite an ugly story actually uh
let's just quickly got time for the mail
front page uh rachel and uh from working
from home boris declares war on civil
servants refusing to head back to the
office
well that's right so civil servants and
i suspect they aren't the only ones
aren't that keen on going back to the
office not certainly not full-time
um and i think this is sort of um
you know that they are representing
a wider uh population that really has
quite mixed feelings about
returning to office work full time and
we're seeing all kinds of hybrid flex
time arrangements come to pass i think
the financial sector is going in that
direction as well um
high tech the tech sector already um
gone in that direction so i think
there's something many people have got
used to working at home including
yourself and jake you're doing a
wonderful job on the paper review
tonight thank you both